shh I'm at work but while I'm at work
quick update on the SAG after
negotiations and what's really going on
between the studios while all this
conversation is going on it's not all
Rosy welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi TV
and movie
[Music]
channel
so I've reported a couple of times and
put a few comments on the Community page
about some disagreement between the
studios Amazon Warner Brothers Paramount
those Studios have been basically
telling Netflix Disney to get their
thumb out of their asses and crack on
they have been really pushing hard and
actually did set a November 1st which is
today deadline for negotiation
to be resolved they basically between
themselves not including Netflix and
Disney agreed that November 1 really was
the day this needed to be done by they
need an agreement by now we need to be
able to get the studios up and running
again we need to St in lots of projects
have we been working on up and running
again it was fine to have a little bit
of a lag between the writers going back
to work and the actors not going back to
work because you know you need the
writers first but now that lag is fine
and we need to crack on
so it's November 1st we still don't have
a deal there was some suggestion that a
deal was very very close but we're now
on Wednesday and it's still not 100%
certain I'm being told that there's
still a confidence that that deal will
be reached this week and that hopefully
next week week after the actors will be
able to get back to work but at the
moment that is only a hope and there are
still some quite big
problems I've also heard though that
actually the people over a Paramount did
make a point in a meeting that happened
uh towards the end of last week with all
of the studios put together one the
representatives from power out pictures
that actually for them and Warner
Brothers really in Amazon with MGM come
into the same bracket as this for them a
lot of the discussion over things like
the subscription fee and things isn't
really relevant it's not their main area
of business and actually for them the
amount of money they're losing every
week because they're not producing any
content is far more than what actually
saga's suggestions would cost them so
what the protracted negotiations are
costing is what actually significantly
more than what just agreeing to
everything they want would
cost there's also a big point that um
again this representative who seemed to
be talking a lot of sense to to me made
to the wider studio audience basically
said look and the whole AI
problem there are certain things about
Ai and the use of AI in our industry or
any industry that is going to be come
under regulation we need governments we
need courts to actually rule on certain
elements of how we're allowed to use Ai
and in what sense there is no point us
having sort of any long-term agreement
on how the use of AI works if then the
Court says the AI cannot be used in this
this and this or what actual AI means or
represents in the workplace AI is
something that the far wider industry
all Industries are going to have to
consider and at the moment governments
don't really have a position on it
there's a big conversation at the moment
this week in the UK the UK are chairing
about how AI should be used in business
so this
representative was basically saying look
we just need a shortterm agreement
basically to say we will not allow AI to
be used
until Regulators etc etc have actually
defined what AI is defined what AI can
be used for Define when AI cannot be
used let's actually allow government the
courts Regulators to lead the way on
this and in the meantime just don't
allow it it's only a three-year contract
RA in the terms of this technology
that's not a particularly long time it
can be resolved in three years time and
when hopefully the legal system Etc will
have caught up now to me that seems a
very logical way to go ahead especially
be seeing that anything they agree could
be deemed as illegal this time next year
anyway if the courts decide so so yeah
it's a long-term process
and let let's just hope that they can
actually come up with something that
makes sense in the next
week so that's where we're at right now
hopefully this will be done pretty soon
but if
not ah the Cinema's already crap anyway
I went to watch the Beetle Juice from 25
years ago the other night because
there's literally nothing else on the
cinema I want to watch and I think the
next six months are going to be a bit
like that to be honest TV's already
starting to get a bit boring because
there's nothing new coming out I'm
starting to watch all the Spanish stuff
on Netflix getting getting desperate but
anyway guys get into the comments Z tell
me what you think is this a plan that
makes sense to the Paramount guy that
was saying this apparently this meeting
last week does that make sense to you
um just get into the comments and tell
me what you're thinking we all just want
this to be over now right I think so if
you're new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification and
please don't tell anybody that I made
this video while I was at
work as always stay safe I'll see you
next
[Music]
time